hey guys so today we are on our way to
Barton jailhouse because we are actually
headed to a Kanye West concert Wow and
this Kanye West concert so originally it
was just for Barton teal so you know we
gifted them these special concert
tickets because Kanye West is performing
the album it awaits and heartbreak
heartbreak
yeah heartbreak yeah that whole album is
performing I know that that's Barton
Gio's number one most like favorite
Kanye West album ever of all time so as
soon as I found out that Kanye was was
having this filter I immediately called
casing on my Omega TC I think we found
the perfect wedding present I know
they're gonna flip their [ __ ] once like
you know they find out about this
concert and so I was hoping to you know
present these tickets to them on their
wedding day but the same day that I
bought the tickets I get to the office
Brandon's there he comes in he's like oh
my god did you guys hear about this
Kanye was comin I mean he didn't know it
wasn't his fault
but he just kept like hyping up like oh
yeah you know Kanye West they perform
like a tow Athens and what is it
heartbreak heartbreak heartbreak
so then Brandon's wrapping up the
concert and then Barton Joe or like oh
my god that's our favorite album like do
we have to go and then I was like no you
know guys like just chill and like I
didn't know what to think and I was just
like don't buy this ticket somebody
wanted for you but in that moment I just
I kind of snapped and I'm like okay guys
okay okay okay okay I actually just
bought you guys the tickets for your
wedding present literally on my way over
here to the office and it just had so
happens to be like you
branding like accidentally pushed me to
to tell them that that was their present
now they know and so yeah we're on our
way
today's the day of the concert yay so
exciting so another wedding present that
we will be presenting them is Casey
actually shot all of the footage or
their wedding date they originally
didn't want any of their friends working
at the wedding but as Tom got closer and
I think they realized it kind of did
want to step away from the wedding or
come out of the wedding with a video
from memory sake so they came back to me
and oh hey I know we said you weren't
going to work during the wedding but can
you help a shoot a wedding video and
I'll go oh yeah sure and I strategically
also edited the video to end with the
end statement of Bart's dad morning Bart
to have a child so that you could be a
grandfather and that leads us into the
actual present yes we actually got them
I guess the third present which is in
this box it's in this box and I'm not
going to tell you guys until Bart and
Jill open it for themselves but I mean
that's a little clue right there as to
what Casey just said with the in
statement of Bart's dad saying he wants
to be a grandfather
you bought him a child we hid a baby in
this box but you guys will see you
really soon because we're about to pull
up to their house I'm so excited for
this oh my god I already know I'm gonna
cry my eyes out and it's happy tears
like I'm really really happy for
themselves I'm excited to see what they
pee
stash it away feel like we're about to
pull a heist or something Oh rare drop
the package they're all hidden they
won't know taking forever and they've
been Park I could see jail vlogging I
think they know that we want to surprise
them with something big [ __ ] so yeah
once a sinister arrived Bart and Jo
weren't here and we're like hey where
are you it's already 6:30 we're supposed
to leave at 6:30 you're pulling there
they're about to get it and so I said hi
guys I knew it I knew it I knew it
because I saw your blogging okay let me
back she tested you're like please it's
important I'm like what's so important
gonna be late I know hurry hurry hurry
come on hurry we're gonna see this in
your rooms okay okay okay okay let's
watch it
what's going on you want to interrupt
guys oh they're going to show us a rough
cut of the wedding video well this is a
customized version I just want to show
you guys what I have so far there we go
welcome grab a time a trinket and grab a
drink it Danny died she's just running
the holy spirit
I know
I
oh my God he's so buggin about that
that's cute
oh good thanks guys and welcome I was
really good thank you and welcome I show
you guys this before
Connie of us cuz you know like cleaning
with is our you know wedding gift to
take anything I can't talk okay
I don't know the relationship between
this behind us well in the spirit of
what your dad said this is funny
boy oh are you having a baby baby bear
what is this is this a blanket oh this
is so cute I'm saying it's crazy cuz I'm
just like imagining our kid in there
yeah I agree you're imagining yourself a
dress how cute and she even embroidered
it PE aww
where the hell is awesome I wanted to be
the first person listening for B Moshe
so that you are you [ __ ] it's so cute
thank you oh I just put my makeup on
okay I am putting okay after that I'm
gonna put my pickup that is so
thoughtful
it's so [ __ ] thoughtful thank you so
much oh then we gotta go now we're late
it's like dying to tell you about this
blanket forever I'm like I love it
I'm like I can't wait to leave it was
[ __ ] awesome now I'm thinking of like
our kid I pictured her kid in there
after bath hey my gosh I need a tissue
everyone's ready for kaya now